- Oh, God.
- 50% alcohol?
- What?
- Whoa!
(Syrian music)
- Syrian Food?
- Oh.
- I know nothing about Syrian food.
- Nada.
- Bring it on.
- Al Mimas Arak, 100 proof.
- Holy shit.
- They know how to get down.
(laughs)
- Oh, man!
- It's like Dimetapp, Robitussin.
It's growing on me every
time I put it back.
(laughs)
- To the top, you heard the lady.
- Activate the grape!
- Whoa!
- I hate black licorice.
- It burns!
- It's like what I imagine
perfume tastes like.
- I'm not Syrian enough.
Keith, I'm really drunk.
- We are a little bit tipsy.
- We are pretty tipsy.
- I think it's gonna freak out
the white in you, and uh...
- (screams) I just saw it!
(screams)
(laughs)
- Eww, don't pick it up!
Get that away from me!
(laughs)
- This is clearly stuffed into intestines.
- Possibly. (laughs)
- It looks like something
I've created before.
(retches)
- It smells incredible.
- Oh yeah!
- There's rice, again.
- Was that garlic?
Get that garlic all on my bowels.
- This doesn't taste bad at all.
- Tastes like garlic.
- This is just a branding problem.
- You can get past the look.
It's worth it.
- Diamond meatball stew.
- Ooh!
(retches)
- Ooh I like that.
- Mmm.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh man, I love it!
- I don't know.
- What is that?
- All I know is that it's good as fuck.
- It's so briny.
- Kinda sour.
- Mucusy.
- Creamy, it's a little powdery.
- [Voiceover] So it's yogurt?
It's yogurt?
- Really?
- What?
- Nothing is more off-putting
than the idea of warm yogurt.
- Somebody invented this
dish when they were like,
"Oh no, my yogurt!
It's still outside!"
- Now wait, wait, wait,
it's not totally bad.
I've got some meatballs.
- Hey cutie pie.
Aww!
- Aww!
- It's like a little Bambi.
- What?
- Syrian pizza!
- Smells like a Jamaican beef patty.
- Is it meat baklava?
- It smells like pumpkin pie and sausage.
- Cheers.
- There's even some cinnamon.
- Like a meat pastry.
- I would definitely eat this again.
- Fuck yeah.
- Bitch, I wasn't done with that.
- Certainly something
like my mom would make.
Is this goat?
- Are there raisins in here?
- There's all these
like, great, warm spices.
- Oh my gosh, this is cinnamony.
Smell that?
Say goodbye to the rice.
- I smell that cardamom.
- Oh my God, that is so good.
- This is bomb as fuck.
- So flavorful.
- This is everything.
- That is melt in your mouth chicken.
- You don't really need
teeth for any of this food.
- You can call me, boom, Tim
Tebow because this is taybeh.
- You can give me that
maqloubeh any day, child, shit.
- Cake time.
Cake, cake, cake, cake.
- Whoo.
- Syrian cake, Syrian cake.
- Let's find out what
meat we're having now.
- Uh.
- Oh my gosh, it's so gunky.
Is this uncooked dough?
- Texture's just right.
- I can't watch you do that
and then want to eat it. (laughs)
- It's got like a floral accent to it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the pistachios won't quit.
They are just like mmm.
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
- It's all cheese.
- Oh my God.
- It's great.
- The pastry is so sweet.
Mmm.
- Make a wedding cake in Knafeh.
- I'm marrying you.
- Seriously.
- Did you say Syria-sly?
- Ohhhhhhh.
- Nailed it.
- Yeah.
- They are beautiful people
with a beautiful culture,
and beautiful food.
- That's good stuff.
- Yeah.
- Holy shit.
(belch)
- Ohhhh.
I think that was the booze.